hello everyone and welcome to another
alpha zero versus dogfish game this is
actually the first game in the alpha
versus Rakesh series that I wanted to
show but for some reason I haven't got
around to doing it up until now but it's
extremely enjoyable and well I hope you
will enjoy it as well as so many of you
have requested more alpha0 games so
let's just see some of your comments on
this matter as you can see mr. Samus is
alpha zero they'll leave the puny humans
alone and give us alpha I very much like
alpha zero versus stockfish I like it
very much
surely more alpha zero versus alpha zero
and stock fish more alpha please more
alpha more alpha alpha zero games please
more alpha zero and stock fish please
would love more alpha zero please do
continue with the Alpha zero games we
really enjoyed the alpha zero games feed
us some more ah god more alpha zero
games please sir so as you can see and
these are only some of the comments
there are a lot more but it would be too
much comments reading but I decided to
show you a bit more but then then we're
done with this for at least well we're
just gonna cover some nice live events
and then after maybe there won't be
anything to show we can return to the
Alpha server storage business but we
have the Capablanca saga coming up soon
so I don't think we'll be missing out on
any Content so without further ado alpha
has the white pieces and we have Knight
to f3 so again we have directly opening
Knight to f6 c4 e6 Knight to c3 and
Bishop to b4 now the names of the
English opening but the names of
variation of Dean which would Bishop to
b4 Queen to c2
we have castles and now a3 asking black
what do you want to do with the bishop
do you want to go back or do you want to
trade on c3 now we have Bishop captures
and c3 Queen captures on c3 and now a5
we have b4 and now comes d6 and here
there were a couple of games not a
couple most of the games in this
position we're continued with Bishop to
b2 which then prevents of course 94 this
is the idea you want to
94 so it doesn't bother your queen and
the bishop will be very nicely developed
here of course if you play this Daniel
yet
checkmate here and there is a one game
from this position where Bishop to b2
was not played where g3 was played I
think it was between Paco Vega who
insult animosity Paco
away who won a very nice game here with
the g3 but here alpha chooses and I
forgot to say this but this is a game
where no opening books were used and
here alpha actually plays III and this
is a new move so off actually doesn't
mind if stockfish goes for this Knights
the e4 idea but let's see what alpha had
in mind stock field loss for it
Knights the four attacks the Queen
prepares Knight to g5 to trade off
Knights we have Queen to c2 and now
comes Knight to g5 and ok we have b5 and
here you already starts to see a theme
here in pretty much all of alpha this
games where it has the white pieces
alpha will push pawns on the Queen side
grab as much space as possible on the
Queen side and will completely disregard
the pawn structure of the King side so
basically you want to overextend on the
Queen side mess up your pawn structure
on the Kings side and then you will have
a very nice game that's what basically
alpha is teaching us and ok stockfish
goes for its Knight character son f3g
captures on f3 and now Queen to f6
attacking the undefended rook on e1 and
also this now double pawn on f3 we have
d for alpha says no problem I'm just
gonna create this very nice strong
center here Queen captures on f3 and now
rook to g1 the rook is attacked on h1
and now you gain the semi-open G file
for attack the bishop is coming to beat
you at some point so already you can see
that white will definitely have
compensation for the bone Knights the d7
starfish wants to develop this Knight is
hope hopefully coming to f6 but alpha
doesn't allow it Bishop to e2 and now
the Queen has to go somewhere
we have cling to f6 and now comes Bishop
to b2 so already you can see that
there's a lot of coordination amongst
the whites pieces and the black it's
only more 15 but black really doesn't
have a
good move here you've just put your
Queen on f6 there's no square for the
knight available you can go here or here
the pawns are covering that if you go b6
you're only gonna be a target for c5
later and you don't really have anywhere
to go from here you can't develop the
rook you can't develop the bishop until
you develop the knight so here stock
which is forced to play again with the
Queen Queen to h4 it seems like it comes
with a with a tempo on the pawn and now
prepares Knight to f6 but alpha doesn't
mind rook to g4 forces the Queen to
capture an h2 but for that the rock now
has a super active Square on g4 and in
the future a queenside castle and this
rook who might come to g1 and then white
will have double rooks on the G file
it's ok Queen captures on h2 and now
comes even if you castle now then after
Queen captures on f2 perhaps black will
grab too much material so instead first
alpha please look to g3 and it's it's a
very nice move it's a hard move to
understand but will show later why this
was played it's it basically prevents
the Queen after the Queen captures the
pawn on f2 from retreating to h4 but
that's a really a crazy line which I'm
sure you're gonna enjoy here who have f5
buy stock fish and now comes castles and
here stock fish can go for this f2 pond
like we've just shown should so does the
rooks presence and g3 prevent the Queen
capturing the f2 point it does but it's
such a such a crazy idea that I'm just
gonna show it to you if Queen captures
on f2 then the idea is rook D to G 1 of
course going after the g7 point and
after g6
now the idea is rook 1 2 G 2 attacking
the Queen Queen to e1 check Bashar
blocks and now the Queen has to escape
Queen to h1 now comes Luke to h2 again
attacking the Queen Queen to e4 and now
Queen to e2 and now there is a very
little black can do against the bishop
to see to burst of the c2 would trap the
Queen so how do you prevent this you can
only do it with f4
make some not an escape route for the
Queen but now if you attack the Queen
Bishop to see to this isn't it the
greatest way to proceed for why because
here black would actually have
compensation after grabbing the two
rooks the Bishop captures pawn chapters
on h2 and after Queen captures on h2 now
you can go look to f1 check you will
develop the knight develop the bishop
and therefore the other row comes to the
F file black will have a lot of
compensation for the Queen but after
this f4 move you don't want to go bash
up the c2 immediately first year you
just move the rook rook g2 h3 attack the
h7 point and the Queen is still in
danger of Bishop to c2 so here rope to
f7 rush up the c2 and now comes f3 Queen
to f2 now comes Queen to g4 and now rook
the g3 and here there's no more no no
escape route for the Queen but it's not
all that all that terrible because now
after Knight to f6 rook captures Knight
captures both the Queen and the rook are
attacked after the Queen moves Knight
captures Queen captures and now f2 by
black
butcher blocks guards f1 but black of
course will try to grab it Bishop
captures rook captures with check and
after King to c2 you will have this
weird position where White has a bishop
and the Queen and black has two roots in
the bishop but before this Bishop and
rogue developed white will have
advantage here and with well with more
space on the Queen side it seems that
stockfish decided this will be better
for alpha so a crazy crazy position and
the stop which does not capture the pawn
rook to f7 prepares to defend here we
have Bishop 2 F 3 alpha now threatens
rook to h1 to trap the black Queen Queen
to h4 and now rook to h1 Queen has to go
back to our six and now kink the b1 a
nice prophylactic move the king is
coming to a-1 from where it will feel
much safer
we have g6 and now rook g2 g1
here black has now created this barrier
and white now has different plans this
rook is now coming to see one
with the ideas of playing c6 and c5 and
b6 I would have a for not allowing white
to push a for himself king 281 and now
comes rough to g7 Black has to wait and
see what white will do as there's really
no way to develop here for black e for
by alpha of course you don't want to
open lines so f4 and now comes c5 if you
D captures D captures then you open up
this dark square diagonal this will be
too strong for white so you don't want
to do this Queen to e7 is played and now
comes look to c1 as planned nice to have
six finally black manages to develop
some pieces and now comes a five we have
D captures on e5 and now rook H 2 e1
before recapturing and now comes a 4 if
you capture here for example you capture
Sun before then Queen to c4 white will
now pile up against the six pawn you can
also attack the pawn this way the the
pawn will the d4 pawn will pawn a fall
at some point so there's no point in
rushing it so after rook h3 you want we
have E for Bishop captures on e4 and now
if you play Knight captures on e4 you
get Queen captures on e4 and there is a
the threat of d5 and then a white will
release the this the power of the dark
square Bishop even if you block with c6
what will still play d5 and after C
captures out Queen captures on f4 and
then after the Queen assumes the d4 or a
v square you will have a the constant
problem of this rook being stuck on g7
as you will not want to allow Queen to
h8 so after Bishop captures on e4 we
have Queen to f8 trying to activate the
rook now the rope can enter the game but
d5 nonetheless alpha doesn't allow black
to consolidate and it's it's really I
mean when you look at this it seems like
an impossible move because of course d5
is protected by the point and the night
but alpha doesn't care
now alpha just wants to release the dark
square bishop and now comes pawn
captures on d5 Bishop back to d3
and now okay now this bishop is strong
but black also can develop now Bishop to
g4 and now comes f3 if you capture on f3
then comes to look to f1 and after you
move the bishop then rook captures on f4
and when you open up DF file now this
rogue is coming to f1 and with the
double rooks and the bishop it will be
an overwhelming position to defend
so after f3 Bishop back to D 7 and now
comes Queen to c3 threatening Queen
captures on f6 and here you have two
options you can either move the knight
which was played in the game or you can
try a rope to f7 rook to f7 is a seems
like a nice idea you defend but it
doesn't work unfortunately for stockfish
because now comes look to g1 and now
white will prepare Bishop captures and
then with the two rooks will deliver
checkmate or black will suffer extreme
material losses so if you try something
like Queen g7 Queen c2 increasing
pressure on g6 and now there's no no
longer away a good way to defend you
will have to move the Queen and now
you'll get Bishop captures and then if H
captures rook captures will win near the
Queen and of course if you try something
like rook to g7 then c6 a very nice idea
captures captures and after you capture
pawn captures here and then after Knight
captures Queen to c6 will be very
powerful as the rook is pinned you
cannot capture here and then after
Knight to be six you will get Bishop to
d4 a very nice move as it now guards the
G 1 square so white is threatening rook
captures here and then the other rook is
coming to g1 and it doesn't matter what
a black plays whatever black plays
you're gonna capture here captures row G
1 and it's all over
so after Queen to c3 Knight to f5 was
played by stockfish but now comes look
to e5 now alpha wants to double up on
the e-file we have c6 as alpha did not
capture under the undie 5 a sawfish now
wants to defend his d5 pawn rook c2 e 1
doubling up and now comes Knight back to
f6 if you try something like rook to e8
here it seems
like a good idea but white will get a
better position out of it after captures
captures now Queen to e5 attacking the
bishop here and after the bishop moves
now you get b6 and black will not have
any any active moves here the only
active move is capturing and c5 but
after Queen captures then comes Queen b8
check and after you eliminate the b7
pawn the past beasts exponent will be
too powerful
so after Roxy - you want we have Knight
to f6 now you can play this as the rook
is blocking the Queen's attack against
the night here
Queen to d4 now going after the f4 pawn
and now comes pawn captures on b5 and
now even bishop the b1 preparing in some
lines for this bishop to come to a2 and
attack the d5 pawn from here we have
Bishop to c6 defending and now comes
look to e6 and now with there there
being a triple attack against the knight
now we have look to have seven and now
white will execute the plan that was
already possible before and that is rook
to g1 now transferring attention to the
g6 pawn we have Queen to g7 and now
comes Queen captures on f4 rook to e8
offering to trade rooks but now rook to
d6 and here Knights the d7 opening up an
attack against against White's queen but
there is an attack against the black
Queen as well so Queen to c1 white of
course doesn't wanna trade Queens we
have looked to f6 offering a rook for
this Bishop but of course this Bishop is
too powerful this bishop pair is like an
upgraded Queen when you look at the
squares they're covering this is this is
insane
so of course alpha doesn't want to trade
this beautiful Bishop for this rook
we have f4 here alpha just wants to push
f5 and bust open the the King side we
have Queen to e7 and now comes rope
captures on f6 Knight captures and now
f5 if you allow F captures on g6 the
game is sorry and the game is over
so stockfish tries not to allow this
Queen to e3 was played but now feel free
to pause the video and find the
winning idea that Alfa planned out
through the entire game for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you you play like alpha zero and for
those of you who just want to enjoyed
show the F captures on g6 will be enough
to win the game so what do you do here
if you capture them of course that's not
even not even interesting rope captures
this coming so the idea is Queen
captures on c1 but now comes pawn
captures on h7 this is what you had to
see and here you have to see that if the
King comes to h8 then Bishop captures
will be checkmate and if you try King to
f8 then again it doesn't work because
White will get another Queen into the
game with Czech and after King g7 Queen
captures here King d7 you lose this
Queen and our black is getting
checkmated a very very soon so after G
captures on h7 King to f7 was played now
h8 will not come with check but now we
have this variation we have rook
captures and c1 and here is what alpha
calculated now you have to capture the
pawn and give up this night there is no
way around it if you try to play
something like rook a shade then rook to
f1 wins the night there's no way for you
to protect the knight and any other
ideas like rook to e6 to protect the
night or lose of course to then you're
no longer protecting the back rank and
if you try to play something like King
to g7 to not allow the pin then comes
rook to g1 and again if you go King to
h8 you get Bishop to f6 checkmate so you
have to go back and now there is a nice
mating attack with Bishop to g6 but you
can also just play a rock to f1 and win
the piece and win the game
so here stock fish is forced to play
Knight captures on h7 we have Bishop
captures on h7 and now rook to e3 so
here alpha is of course up a piece this
is now a winning position but stock fish
is still up to pawns so how will offer
do this alpha will now pull back the
rook activate the King and use the dark
squares to enter blacks King side here
we have B 4 a 5 B 6 and that that's the
plan now it's only a matter of realizing
that plan
so let's see how alpha does it rook to
d1 King te8 we have king - a - Bishop to
d7 rush up to d4 kicking away the rook
rook to h3 and vessel goes back there
should be six now comes rook to e1
pinning the bishop now king 37 defending
the bishop and now King 2b - so slowly
but surely the king is finding his way
up the board now but you still can do it
because the rook from h3 is not allowing
it we have looked to f3 and now rook to
e5 look the g3 now comes look to e3
kicking away the rook if you try drugs
then it's all over
look the G - and now King can finally
come up the board we have rook here now
you can't go Kingdom before because your
Bishop is hanging so first rook to a3
King goes back and now rook to F to look
to g3 check even if you keep the rook
here and then after this rook comes to
d2 the bishop will be protected and the
King will be able to go up the board so
black doesn't have to wait for that rook
the g3 check King before rook to g4
pinning the bishop and attacking it but
now rook to d2 s planned Bishop to d7
now comes King to a5 rook to f4 we have
Bishop to e5 attacking the rook rook
goes back and now rook to d3 not
allowing this point to be captured we
have grouped to have two attacking the
bishop bishop to d1 and now comes Bishop
to c6 and now comes came to b6
this is move 67 and it was in this
position that stockfish resigned the
game there is nothing to be done here
so one one way you could go about this
you basically just have to get this
Bishop to e2 and attack the b5 point and
there's no way for black to defend it
and then black will simply start losing
material and it's over let's say black
makes a move Ruby g2 you will now go
rook III defended the e2 square and
after black makes any other move then
comes Bishop to e2 and the game is over
captures captures captures everything
captures and that is that so after King
to b6 stockfish resign the game and
alpha again created a master
peace as as as offered us so yeah that's
basically what Alpha Thoris here just
push the pawns as far as you can on the
Queen side you know we can the dark
squares and then ruin your pawn
structure on the King side as well grab
some open lines sacrifice more points
and and win the game so try that in your
own games and see how it goes
best of luck to you of course I would
like to thank Abhishek Kumar Martin
official Dan Rosner Preston yadegar and
Tommaso Bruni for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check
through my previous video so you're
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon hopefully with a more interesting
content thank you all and I'll see you
soon